so as some of you might have noticed I
am a woman
um I'm white uh I have a disability and
when I think about politics and when I
talk about politics a lot of those
identities come into it so when I think
about austerity I look at how austerity
affects certain groups more than others
so in particular austerity affects women
82 percent of all cuts that the
government have made are impact women
if you look at the if you look at the
pay gap for instance women are paid less
than men but if you narrow it down black
women are paid a lot less than than
other than other people
um so when you think about politics
identity does have to come into it
because everybody experiences things
differently uh you know personally but
also in terms of economics in terms of
uh you know how it affects the community
Etc
um and when I think about the people
well when I come across the people who
complain about this
they always seem to be exclusively
Boomers sorry
um I am closer in age to uh kamal's
daughter than Kamal so I am I am other
generation that is part uh you know
partly interested in identity politics
um and I don't think it I don't think it
deflates things I think you know people
uh live their life in a normal way uh
and obviously your identity is part of
that so everything that affects you
everything that makes you makes up makes
up uh the person that is you including
your likes your hobbies or dislikes Etc
it all comes together to form a whole
person and I don't think that you know
talking to people and understanding that
people have different views different
experiences of life you know because of
different identities I don't think it
actually like deflates things I don't
think it puts people in a box I think it
allows us to be more expansive with uh
policy I think it allows us to look at
uh political policy and think about how
different groups will be affected by it
and you know and therefore stop uh
discrimination within that kind of thing
um
but there's a lot there's a huge amount
of concern about universities about
people being no platformed about people
not being allowed to speak Etc
um and I always find it really really
fascinating that so many people get
upset by a small number of students in
the Student Union uh when almost nobody
else will have heard of these little
these small societies these small groups
um
and I think it's I think the big problem
is that we have older people who have uh
you know columns in big magazines huge
access to the media uh constantly saying
that they are being silenced I know this
because they write constantly that that
they are being silenced they go on TV to
talk about the fact that they have been
silenced
and
you know I think I think they were I
wouldn't be constantly hearing about
them
and I think it you know I think actually
identity politics helps those people
because it allows them to constantly
Place articles in The Spectator
um in spiked magazine in all sorts of
places talking about the fact that they
have been silenced and the identity
politics is ruining their life Etc
um
and you know thinking about Lionel
speech I have a lot of friends who are
white men and I don't look at them and
think good Lord You're so privileged
it's disgusting uh because they are my
friends and I don't think of people you
know in small you know I don't put
people in the small boxes I don't look
at them as a you know having a tick box
on their chest that explains things
about them
um I think that you know for instance me
having having a disability changes my
life somewhat I'm in hospital a lot my
friends know that and come and see me
um but it doesn't really change anything
else I might need some things like for
instance if we decide to have strobe
lighting here uh I wouldn't be able to
sit on stage but that's about it
um
don't do that
uh and I find it really really
fascinating that the big Panic comes
from older people a very very small
number of older people who uh you know
who as like you know Lionel was saying
that the people who are into identity
politics are relatively wealthy tend to
be white Etc
um but whenever I read articles about
people being silenced about people being
uh get kicked out by identity politics
it's always homeowners in their 50s it's
always people who are relatively
comfortable haven't lived through uh the
you know the global financial crash
didn't really affect them
um
and it seems you know it seems such an
obsession with uh with those people
um I've met people who uh were
absolutely desperate to get removed from
panels just because they wanted to talk
about the packlash that came with it and
they knew that if they were removed from
a small panel in student union they
could make a huge amount of money
talking about it you know going on the
BBC talking about how they were silent
writing as a spectator about how they
were silenced and absolutely nobody at
any point thinking why clearly they
aren't clearly this person's being
polished everywhere
um
I think identity politics is actually
really really helpful in terms of uh
making sure that we think uh more deeply
about how policy affects people about
how we can stop kind of get you know
gaps in uh admissions to University how
we can stop people being paid less how
we can look at the fact that if you were
disabled you are less likely to get a
job and how we can you know change
things to bring other people in
um and I think that
I think that we have to move past the
you know terrifying fear that a lot of
Boomers have around this uh you know
people when I look at my friends I don't
I you know I don't have a tick box in my
head that appears like uh you know like
some kind of sci-fi thing uh that breaks
down what they are and who they are we
might have conversations about kind of
you know so I was having a conversation
with my friend the other day about the
fact that they had been the victim of a
homophobic attack
um but identity doesn't always come up
and sometimes it does and it's very I
think it's a lot more useful to talk
about it and think about how
discrimination happens and how we can
stop that from happening
um one one really really key bit uh I
think uh David will talk about this is
University admissions so for instance
Oxford you know had a huge race problem
they have a huge class problem
um and you know bringing that up and
talking about it means that they will
actually take some some action and think
about that there have been some court
cases where people have looked at the
fact that that you know certain policies
are bound to affect women therefore they
are discriminatory uh other policies for
instance like exclusively seem to hit
disabled people and those people have
gone to court and talked about the fact
they've been discriminated against and
often won the cases and changed the
policy so I think that you know if we
want to have a more equal Society there
is no way we can do that without
thinking about identity without thinking
about uh how certain things mean that
other people find it harder to get into
certain jobs find it harder to reach
certain things or even you know come
into a building because there isn't a
wheelchair ramp
um so I think that you know identity
politics is not about deciding who uh
who is the villain who is the most
privileged who we should you know never
ever talk about and and attack and we
talk about their privilege I think it's
much more about making sure that our
society is more welcoming to people and
that political policy doesn't
discriminate against uh individuals and
big groups it does at the moment
austerity massively affects women and it
massively you know if you are a woman
and you are disabled you're doubly
discriminated against by certain
policies that is identity politics and
you know I think we need to remember
that
if we are making policy it needs to be
more equal it needs to make sure that
for instance
um
if you are a young black person and
you're applying for a certain job uh you
know or a place in the University you
aren't discriminated against by uh the
way that the interview takes place
um and so I think identity politics is
about equality it's about making sure
that everybody has the same access and
that access might be slightly different
based on their identity
um and I think that it's led to a lot of
people thinking more deeply about how
they act and how Society should be built
so uh I you know I'm against emotion I
think that we should be more equal and I
think the identity politics is key to
that we can't move past identity we
can't ignore identity
um and I think that you know maybe at
some point the Boomers will understand
that
thank you very much Dawn thank you very
much
um our next speaker for the motion uh
Trevor Phillips to my right uh was chair
of the equality and Human Rights
Commission between 2003 and
2012. the co-founder of the diversity
analytics consultancy Weber Phillips uh
and he is presently chairman of the
index on censorship he's a director of
the Barbican Arts Center and vice
president of the royal television
Society ciao
[Applause]
well good evening and thank you for
inviting me to be part of this
discussion I didn't really to be
absolutely honest with you I didn't
really know what Intelligence Squared
was before I was asked to be part of
this it's a tribute to their
organization that this number of people
can turn out on a lovely evening where
you could be doing something much better
to listen to us thank you so thank you
so much so let me introduce myself I'm
the 10th of 10 children of an immigrant
family came here in 1950.
we're descendants of slaves including a
woman the earliest known member of our
family
she was called Happy
presumably some slave owner's idea of a
great joke
further back we would have come from the
mandinka or Fellaini people of West
Africa like David
he also comes from Guyana that's a whole
other identity story to tell you but
we're great my ancestors were there for
Muslims
but of course we had all that whipped
out of us probably in our case by the
biggest plantation owners in British
Guyana John Gladstone yes the father of
the liberal Prime Minister William Glenn
Gladstone and the largest single
beneficiary of compensation after
abolition
I also have a professional identity I
used to do TV don't do much these days
I've only made three films in the last
20 years
before that with my brother Mike I wrote
the book and made the series which told
the Windrush story first today I
occasionally write for newspapers and
magazines but mostly I'm basically a
boring businessman I chair a talent
business called Green Park and for the
past four years
I was president of the Council of the
John Lewis partnership I run a small
data analytics business is probably a
legacy of my time as a chemist when I
was young I said all that out to try to
explain
why I come at this debate from the way I
do
my background may explain some of what
I say
I agree with
some of what dorm said by the way
identity is more important because it
now represents some real interests that
for the first time in many centuries
has a voice
women
obviously
minorities when my father came here the
white family who lived across the road
could afford to be friendly with us they
knew that no matter how clever my dad
was
how hard he worked how ambitious he
might be when it came to getting a job
or a house or a loan we would never be
ahead of them in the queue
that divided us from them
not income not the area we live but that
thing that thing
and by the way it's not just poor people
of color who suffer because we'll have
an argument no doubt about class here
when I was chairman of the commission
for racial equality
who were most affected who wept in my
office
well not young black men harassed by the
police
they were
the teacher who knew
that because he was black oration he
would never become a department head
the lawyer
who knew that no matter how clever she
was and how hard she worked she was
never going to take silk
and the doctors who knew that they would
always be junior doctors and never
Consultants
they had done everything that this
Society after them everything
but the prison of their skin
kept them in a place that meant they
would never
reap the rewards of their diligence
so I understand all of that and if
that's all that identity politics were
about
to be short debate
we could also we agree
there are some other things that it
shouldn't it's not about I was the nus
president
who
wrote and moved and persuaded
the NES conference in 1973 to adopt the
no platform policy we wanted to keep
fascists off campus
nobody today thinks that Jermaine Greer
or Julie bindle should be in that
category we can agree about that
nobody today thinks that white men
should continue staging the sitting they
do in the boardrooms of our great
companies
except then
we don't have to have an argument about
that
and nobody
believes that it's okay to abuse public
figures I got my first bag full of hate
mail
when I became the nus president in
1978 I was 24 years old and I had a
whole bag full of it including a
Charming cartoon which Drew my own
lynching nobody will argue that that
should be part of our politics so I
don't think we need to devote a lot of
time to all of that
nor should we spend a lot of time
comforting ourselves with the thought
that we are virtuous and our folks out
there who aren't the fact that none of
us is Nigel farage doesn't let us off
the hook on this issue
clever and nice people can be racist too
Albert Einstein called the Chinese an
industrious filthy obtuse people
one of my friends and somebody I admire
in politics
once called on the government he led to
ensure British jobs for British workers
we may tonight talk about institutional
racism or sexism Stokely Carmichael came
up with that phrase for a very specific
reason it was a critique of Martin
Luther King
Carmichael said that point where he was
making was that racism was so baked into
society that you could have a police
force full of black angels and they
might still be shooting black people
everybody said that don't be ridiculous
50 years on
the killings of young black men all over
the USA Often by black police officers
says that Carmichael was right
so tonight this is really for me about
politics and its place in society
there's only one reason for politics to
exist and that is to help us solve
problems
now for over a century and a half our
political architectures followed
economic and social divisions workers to
the left bosses to the right
but we're in an era of extreme possibly
unprecedented disruption
and the real tribal divide in our
society symbolized the deepest
differences about what kind of people we
want to be
I'm a remainer
Pro globalization massively plural
immigration Pro technology socially
liberal london-centric you'd expect that
but I don't disrespect my many relatives
who live in say Essex or Nottingham who
feel just as passionately
anti-globalization cautious about
immigration and that includes my black
relatives
anti-digitization and who loathe
London's arrogance
a survey taken after the referendum
asked about people's attitude to various
topics on the economy on capitalism
there was absolutely no difference
between remainers and leave us 51
thought capitalism was a force for ill
49 Force for good
asked about multiculturalism
of remainers thought it was a Force for
good 81 percent of leavers thought it
was a force for ill 60 of remainers were
pro-feminism lower than I'd expect
74 percent of leavers were against
feminism my point is it is these issues
of identity that aren't dividing us
there's really about one thing
identity politics is
a politics that is tearing our society
apart I think that's objectively true
but perhaps where I differ
with the other panelists possibly
including Lionel is that they will all
lament this fact I don't I think it is a
wonderful thing
our opponents confront the world with
timidity in the hope that the existing
political architecture can be tweaked
and twisted into coping
politoing B versus Richard Littlejohn
labor versus Tory none of that worked
for me offer 60 of the British people
who say there is nobody I can vote for
if you really believe in Liberation this
is going to be a struggle what makes you
think that straight white propertied men
are going to give it up without a fight
our society will be torn apart in order
to get Justice
we need a political map now that allows
us to represent the true divisions in
our society one of my daughters said to
me when I told her what I was going to
say tonight
oh I see you're channeling Samuel L
Jackson
what the hell do you mean well she said
Sam would just get up and he'd say this
everything's changing
politics has got to change too let's
just tear this down and
start something new
thank you very much uh Trevor uh
fortunately this isn't being uh
broadcast live on the BBC because it's
quite a lot of bad language I feel
around us which is uh to be warned
against before I call our next uh
speaker up just to say that I have the
results in front of me of your initial
votes which I will be announcing after
our fourth speaker has finished and then
once David Lammy has finished we'll be
coming to the floor for your chance to
question
these brainy folk up here before voting
again
so but before all that we'll go to our
final speaker against the motion
identity politics is tearing Society
apart David Lammy labor MP for Tottenham
one of parliament's most prominent
campaigners for social justice famously
led the recent campaign for the Windrush
generation to be granted British
citizenship he's fought for justice for
the grenfold Tower of families and of
course has run the high profile campaign
calling on Oxbridge to improve access
for students from underrepresented and
disadvantaged backgrounds David the
floor is yours
great
so I'm listening to the speakers
and I'm thinking about a young David
Lammy
growing up in Tottenham in the 1970s
it's a young David Lammy that looks like
Michael Jackson and wants to be Michael
Jackson
and that young David Lammy would never
have believed
that
the tide of human progress would bring
me here in front of you
able to articulate to speak to have the
confidence to do that
I was also thinking of another young but
a bit older David Lambie who walked into
the House of Commons at the beginning of
that Tony Blair government
by that point I look more like Denzel
Washington
this was a period of consensus politics
Clinton
Blair
um
new labor
things were coming together we had 10
consecutive quarters of growth
and the kind of cool Britannia emerged
where you know there were a lot of drugs
as well things but you know
dance music but people loved one another
here I am
I now look like Forest Whitaker
tomorrow people will be voting in the
European elections and many will vote
for what I see as hard right parties and
positions
this is an age of trump
of farage of Jacob reese-mogg of Boris
Johnson
and we are accusing identity politics of
tearing
Society apart
the great story
of the 20th century
was probably democracy
but if there is a second story
theme that acts that Century surely it
is rights
and that by the end of that Century so
many human beings who started off at the
beginning of the 20th century subjugated
oppressed could actually begin to
self-actualize in their own lifetimes
women
got the vote
and with the invention of the pill
control over their own bodies
ethnic minorities
colonize remember those pink bits of the
atlas over so much of the world
broke off because of the powerful words
and behavior of people like Gandhi from
that colonization workers
came from being exploited birthed
movements like the labor party and I
still believe at its best the best
Progressive cause in our country
and now
same-sex marriage and those who are LGBT
taking their place when it's only in
1967.
that you could be imprisoned because of
the person that you love that is a
remarkable story the story that is the
story of the 20th century and of course
that is a story about identity because
when Martin Luther King spoke
and he talked about judging somebody
by the
character
of their soul not by the color of their
skin
have we arrived at that and and even
though that was a goal
even though that was a goal he didn't
park his identity at the door to get
that goal and neither did Harvey Milk
fighting for gay rights in San Francisco
and Beyond and all those fighting for
disability rights so for me identity
politics is about empathy
it is about dignity and my God I look
Nigel farage in the face and I say it's
about compassion compassion for your
fellow human being so we stand by that
progress despite all that we have to do
we're now
in a period where those on the right
dismiss it
when I raise concerns about who should
lead the inquiry into those poor people
that died
desperately included a friend of mine on
the 20th floor of grenfill tower burned
to death a young woman called Khadijah
say and I raised questions about who
should lead that inquiry
because actually in the role that I play
in public life someone should say does
it have to be another white male
privileged upper-class judge
because
can't do a good job
Garmin did a good job when he led the
riots into the Brixton riots but is
there not in Britain in 2019
an ethnic minority lawyer
or even a woman
that could take that role and I say that
at a point in our country where only
seven percent of the judges are from an
ethnic minority background and we have
one one woman on our Supreme Court
progress so much more so much more to do
and those on the left of course
class
and economic equal inequality
have to be challenged That's the basis
of my politics but those who fight for
rights today do not stand opposed to
issues of
um inequality that exists in our society
just as there were LGBT people who set
up solid disparity funds to fight for
the miners you can be alongside those in
that battle for
um against inequality in our society and
yes there are moments when it goes too
far if you're tweeting or writing white
people or trash kill all men that is
identity politics that I would not want
to associate myself with but let us be
clear
on the proposition
let us really
single in on what may be tearing our
society apart
populism
might well be tearing our society apart
populism on the hard right and populism
on the hard left
austerity
cuts
brutal cuts to local authorities right
up and down the country
the biggest north-south divide since
1911. that may be tearing our society
apart Grim poverty
chronic housing conditions right across
this city that means so many people who
could be in this audience aren't in this
audience that could be tearing our
society apart
gross inequality
with 44 of the UK's wealth owned by just
10 percent of our population
50 percent of the land in the UK owned
by one percent of the population that
could be the proposition that could be
tearing our society apart but instead
this proposition asks you blame the
Bangladeshi woman
blame the trans man
blame the individual with disability
and then they say they're victims and we
heard that language from Lionel
victimhood
the victimhood that is being manipulated
in our country is a victimhood that's
being peddled today by Nigel farage it
is not the victimhood of the people I
just described
so reject this proposition it is not
tearing our society apart it's an ark
that begins with people like Mandela
Martin Luther King Gandhi Emily pankhus
stand alongside it because in the age
that we are in there is a big difference
between dignity compassion and human
rights and the populism that would rip
our country asunder